a March led by ten coffins a symbolic
reference to the people who died in
December when the Army opened fire at
protesters near the airport in the
Andean city of ayakucho
my son was taken from me he was 20 years
old I want Justice
her family saw the victims blame
president Dina voluarte for the violent
Crackdown and want her resignation
[Music]
she's a murderer a dictator entrenched
with Congress we demand an immediate
resignation
there were protests in several regions
on Wednesday highways were blocked in
Cusco in puno many clashed with police
demanding new elections to be held
immediately although many different
groups around the country want different
things they're not coordinating among
regions there is one voice being heard
louder and louder and that is the demand
for closing of Congress and the reform
of the Constitution
74 year old Enrique Torres has no time
to join protests he lives from crop to
crop barely feeding his family as he
plants beans he reflects on his anger at
peduce political Elite Farmers like me
suffer from a lack of rain but
congressmen don't do anything for us
like improvements or irrigation how must
we live that is what I asked politicians
that the laws changed to amend the
Constitution to one that would favor all
of us
in the district of sokosina yakucho most
Farmers live like Enrique work in the
fields and these days listening to the
news of the Nationwide discontent they
say they share
Community leader Hilda Rodriguez says
politicians never remember them
the rich politicians take advantage of
us for them laws and Justice exists but
there's no law or Justice for us we want
equality for our people
as protests resumed president boluarte
is urging for peace the government says
development and growth can't stop and is
promising Security Forces will act
responsibly while protecting private and
public property
but for the people in socos and many
other poor regions in Peru development
and growth is just a distant dream
Mariana Los Angeles